doctor maggie adair in pocock welcome
so
now that you're here
with with tom daley uh
a man who's more dependent on gravity
than most people that's true really yes
will would there be another planet for
him
well there's all sorts of planets out
there um i think your best bet would be
mars you can't breathe the atmosphere um
but it would be quite exciting i mean
people could live on mars it's as cold
as antarctica so but it is habitable
mostly other planets in the solar system
you just wouldn't want to go there okay
so you wouldn't he wouldn't wear a
swimsuit but he
maybe a swimsuit underneath the
spacesuit
but would there be a gravity there oh
yes there is but it's about a third of
the gravity on earth
so if you there's um the tallest um
volcano in the solar system called
olympus mons
and um because the gravity is less you
can imagine sorry you're strung up
you're fit so it'll probably still take
me a while to get up there but because
you're fit you could sort of stride up
there because there's less gravity and
your muscles are tuned for earth so
actually if you did a dive i mean we did
so many summer camps
let's go for training camp
the next olympics on mars
it's gonna happen yeah
it's it's it's not i i have a few
questions about space of course but i i
have to i have to ask you first because
it was not not a given that you were to
become a space scientist
was it no um i i think i was an unlikely
candidate i think that's probably the
best way to put it
um my parents pushed up when i was four
years old and i went to 13 different
schools growing up
i told that to a child the other day she
said how naughty were you
so sometimes i was with my mum and
sometimes i was with my dad so i moved
around a lot and i also have a condition
called do you so sorry do you remember
that as a good thing or a bad thing
it's quite i think i'm definitely a
glass half full sort of person
and um
i remember moving around a lot and i
think it gave me skills
as i and my husband for instance he's
got friends that go back to primary
school and unfortunately i don't have
that but i i'm in an unusual situation
i'm quite used to fitting in because i'm
used to chopping and changing and sort
of being in a different circumstance and
almost it's sort of like a chameleon you
sort of blend into your surroundings so
i think it gave me some some skills but
i did lose out on other things so you
mentioned
a condition yes a dyslexia now i used to
say i suffer from dyslexia but now i see
it as my secret superpower
how promised that well because um when i
was at school
at school it's all about reading and
writing and and these are things that
dyslexics find really hard but as a
dyslexic you have really good 3d spatial
awareness so you were talking about
tumbling and sort of assessing your and
sort of speeding up and slowing down
dyslexia would be perfect at that
because we sort of assess our um
we're very logical as well so there are
all these skills which i didn't know
about when i was growing up but now i'm
older and i've gone through the system i
can see the benefit of these skills
um
you you have i
i mean now now you're very established
and you're a president of the the the
science society in in in britain and and
so on but but have you met a lot of
assumptions uh
that you couldn't be a scientist through
the years yes and so for growing up it's
just like you were saying so you had
that dream
of being of winning a gold medal and
it's sort of like a sort of a sometimes
it seems almost unobtainable uh and
growing up people would tell me a sort
of oh
why don't you go into nursing you know
that's scientific that nursing is a
fantastic job but when you were showing
those images earlier i was thinking oh
wow that's what makes my heart sing and
but i think everybody needs that
something a goal to attain i like to
call it the desire to aspire as when i
go out and speak to kids that's what i
like to tell them have a some crazy
dream because it means you overcome
hurdles along the way
um
[Applause]
most people i've heard about the the
hubble telescope
but you've been a part of updating it to
or actually change it to a different
telescope a better telescope yes
what's the difference between the hubble
and the new one yes so for a while it
was called the next generation space
telescope which sounded really star trek
and they came back and said we're going
to call it the james webb space
telescope and everybody said who the
heck is james west
and it turns out he was the second
administrator of nasa and but he was um
the guiding force for the apollo moon
landings and all of that
now it's quite interesting because it is
really the next generation space
telescope because the hubble space
telescope has transformed our
understanding of the universe i mean
some of the images it shows it's just ah
this is so beautiful but it's also
giving us an understanding of our place
in the universe so for instance um
within our galaxy there are 300 billion
stars but hubble showed us that in
within the universe there are about a
hundred billion galaxies and each one of
those galaxies has a cluster of stars
they're only billions and billions of
stars so we are very insignificant
i lay awake at night
those things are just like the scale of
like what we are compared to what's ours
where does it end i mean
where does it end
well it's a short answer it's your
answer
do you believe that there is a
containment to the universe because we
believe the universe started with a big
bang and we believe it's expanding
outwards so it has a finite edge but um
but the edge is so far away we can't see
it because it takes so long for light to
travel from that edge to us but outside
that edge
see in the old days and when people said
oh what came before the big bang we'll
say
well space and time were created in the
big band so there was nothing before it
but now we're playing with all sorts of
interesting ideas like sort of maybe a
multiverse multiple universes uh leaping
into existence and maybe sort of
diminishing and so our universe might be
just part of something much much bigger
and our universe is pretty big as it is
could have been a science experiment
gone wrong and then all of a sudden like
we're here
you know
they came up with humans what did we go
wrong
there has been some interesting uh news
lately about about space i mean
first of all you had you have these
pictures that have been released
from u.s pilots
taken by u.s pilots uh
jet fighter pilots yes uh through the
airs
and
it's
they can't it's very mysterious they
can't really explain what those pictures
are it's shadows and things that i mean
do what do you reckon it is it's quite
interesting because if you ask me the
question do i believe there's life out
there i'd say yes
because it's that numbers game if you
look at the number of stars in our
galaxy each star is a sun like our sun
now we're detecting what we call
exoplanets going around those stars
and then so that's 300 billion stars in
our galaxy 100 billion galaxies i think
it's very conceited to think that life
only occurred here it's just a matter of
probability
but at the same time the universe is
vast and so to travel from our solar
system to the next-door neighbor solar
system using current technology would
take about 76 000 years and so even if
there are aliens out there how will they
find us although
we leak television signals into space
and so they could be watching this
programme
[Applause]
i think i should adjust my ratings
but but but do you think that
they would have any interest in coming
here or at all
it's an age-old question um there is an
organization called seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
and um sometimes some people think we're
we send messages out into space
sometimes and some people think we
should and some people think we
shouldn't
because if the aliens don't know we're
here and if they can detect us and find
ways of getting to us they have much
better technology than us
so you know should we be over here come
and get us although i do ask what would
be unique on earth that they wouldn't
find out there in the universe apart
from possibly life
so but at the same time i want to know
that we're part of something amazing i i
so want to find life out there i think
it would change the human experience if
we knew we're not alone
but i i think that for for tom and me
it's like they i i i shouldn't speak for
you but but i i i imagine some
a little shorter than me uh yeah yeah
and
perhaps white or green or
without so much clothes yeah
that's your image of an alien that's my
image because i grew up with that and
i've seen these films and but in in your
view what would life be
you see and i think uh as scientists we
have we suffer from the same problem as
you do that we have seen aliens in a
certain way
and all the life here on earth for
instance is dependent on water it's sort
of carbon-based so we are very narrowed
in our thinking about life but sometimes
i like to sort of uh throw that out of
the window and think you know what if
life for life not as we know it
so for instance um our bodies are based
on sort of carbon our dna our
functioning is based on carbon but if
you look at the periodic table the next
one down is silicon
so a few years ago i was invited to draw
an alien um which would live on another
planet and at that time we were finding
these hot jupiters so big gaseous
planets and so i had this sort of
blobless creature that was made of
silicon and um they didn't sort of eat
or and they didn't speak they just sort
of sucked in gases and and they
communicated through lights because they
can absorb energy from the sun and then
sort of pass it from one to another so i
think sometimes we need to think outside
the box in terms of aliens but i also
love the idea that maybe we go to mars
and we've got our praise and we're sort
of digging around oh no no life here and
there's aliens
there has also been some news about
some some signals some some radio bursts
that are repeating
uh
and they can't explain that
uh can you
no no i can't it's quite interesting
because um a long time ago we found a
repeated signal of a radio wave and went
beep beep beep beep and they were first
detected by a woman called jocelyn bell
brunell
and she found these and she took them to
her supervisor and said look look what
i've found and the supervisor jocelyn
have you found little green men and he
was a bit dismissive about it but it
turned out that what she had found were
something called a pulsar and it's a
collapsed star that spins very fast and
it has a beam of radio waves coming out
of it and so as it spins the beam passes
past earth and that's what we detect but
there are other beams of radio waves um
these are rapid
radio waves and we don't know what they
are because what they do is they give
out in a millisecond they give out as
much energy as the sun gives out in
three days and they pump this out with
it's like a ferocious release and we
have no idea what's causing them so
scientists we're detecting them but we
don't know what they are but i love that
it's a mystery
do you think
i i think it's uh it's very irritating
that we can't get an answer
but you say it's a mystery but
are there any theories that they are
trying to communicate with us or
um so there's a huge amount of energy so
and so what we can do is we can analyze
it so i say it's sort of a very short
sort of almost like a violent burst and
we look at the sort of the signature the
frequencies and things like that we
haven't found anything in them yet but
of course
this is alien if it was alien um how
would we decipher it we might be missing
something but there but just like um
sort of with the pulsars there might be
a natural phenomena but there's so many
mysteries in space and astronomy we
don't know what 94 of the universe is
made of it's really embarrassing
we know it's out there we call it dark
energy dark matter but we don't actually
know what it is but i love it because it
keeps me in a job
also don't you think that there's a part
of us that that just wish that we're not
alone because we're so alone if we're
alone yes yes because in that in that
universe that we describe with so many
stars so many planets if we are alone
it almost feels as if something's gone
wrong it's like we are an experiment
that's gone wrong because why would we
be alone um
because the probability would be that
there would be other life out there
and also if you look at the evolution of
life on earth
as soon as planet earth was able to have
life life seemed to appear but it took a
long time to get to our level of
sophistication if that's what we call it
and so um i think if in the future we
are looking at these exoplanets we will
detect life out there i won't put the
date on it but i think we will find it
but i think the most likely thing we're
finding is sort of simple life you sort
of you know bacteria sort of you know as
simple cells to find intelligent life is
a lot harder yeah probably quite
worrying
people watching this program
do you reflect on these things
honestly like when you i start to think
about what could be out there i'm just
like i almost would rather just think
we're in like the hunger games and we're
just a big simulation there's someone
like watching us because
the fact that there is so much space
out there is just
mind-boggling to me like i say i
literally stay awake at night thinking
about how insignificant everything we're
doing here really is in comparison but
it's funny because i think there's two
mindsets sort of the mindset that oh my
goodness it's big and it's scary and
it's all out there but there's another
mindset say we are part of something
truly amazing we are part of the
universe and yeah we are a small part of
the universe but we are part of that
fantastic phenomenal huge experience
gives you a great sense of perspective i
think that's the one thing it's just
like the perspective of like
you know sometimes we get so invested in
what's going on in our worlds that we're
it's so we make ourselves to be like
this oh no this is happening it's gonna
this is this is terrible this is this
but actually just taking a step back and
having that perspective i think is also
a good thing but i think that's why
because you were talking about knitting
as a mindfulness i think stargazing can
really help with that as well and i
think lots of people were taking that up
during covid because they're sort of
trapped indoors they sort of they they
can't continue with their usual life and
so just sort of sitting outside and i do
it with my daughter we sit outside and
sit on a clear night and just look up
and take it all in and then okay don't
worry especially after a busy hectic day
yeah because i don't think you can
forget about the things that matter in
our lives but it's nice to contemplate
the big what's the best question you
ever got from your daughter oh for my
daughter
gosh
actually she didn't i'm trying to think
because she asked me a question the
other day
she does ask me sort of why why the
aliens haven't come i mean
yeah
living in our garden yeah yeah yeah i i
i talk about sort of the things
that i ask
a few years ago um because i was saying
i want to go out in space and she says
she wants to come too but is that your
dream oh all my life oh really yes and
it's funny because from i was born in
1968 1969 the moon landings happened so
i can't remember the moon landings and
people say i was taking my first wobbly
steps as neil armstrong was taking his
giant leap
but at the same time i can't remember it
but it set the tone of my life
right from the get-go growing up yes yes
i've got to get out there so so if jeff
bezos
called you now and said can you come
tomorrow i'm gonna
send me up yeah
yes it's funny because if you ask me uh
11 years ago i would yeah sure i've got
my bag on packs
but now because i have my daughter
that's the only thing that has changed
it
and it's funny i knew before i had my
daughter that it would change that
strong desire in me so now it's a bit
more of a retirement
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
plan as as i'm sure it did for you also
it changes perspective yeah having a kid
i think that's the big thing when you
become a parent like they become your
number one so everything else feels very
not insignificant but it very much takes
a back seat and then you always think
about them before you think about
anything else and also you become less
of a risky risk taker yeah i used to i
used to love like bungee jumping
skydiving all of that but now like i
think well what would i what would
happen if i
had an accident and what would my son
robbie do and so yeah it definitely does
change the way you think you you have
one thing in common i think and that is
you both met the queen elizabeth
yes
yes yeah how how does that work uh is
that
i mean is it like
you were invited to buckingham palace
after yeah after the after the olympics
in yeah 2008 and 2016. yeah yeah and
did it go well did it
yeah i mean like basically you ever they
come around before and kind of explain
the etiquette of like what you're
supposed to say and what you're supposed
to do and
you know and she might not ever come up
to you in the in the scenario and you're
never meant to put your hand out to
shake her hand she has to offer her hand
to you and there's lots of little things
which so it becomes quite a panicky like
moment when you're like oh my gosh
and you end up like oh my god
but also she talks really quietly and
it's so hard to hear her but obviously
you can't say sorry sorry can you can
you repeat that
like but you can't like you just like
you just have to like kind of like nod
smile and just hope she hasn't just
asked you a question because it's like
she does she's and she but she was so
sweet she was so sweet yes but so you
you went very close then
yeah i mean we were like she was stood
right in front of me and i was still
like
sorry uh but yeah because at the time
when we went into some other athletes
and she said she commented on her height
compared to some of the other athletes
were in the room and she said that maybe
because she was like me myself and the
other gymnasts were uh the smaller ones
were like maybe i should try gymnastics
or diving so she was like fully game to
get involved in the
sport thank you
yeah right you were you were honored by
her for your communication skills
actually for communicating science yes
uh how was that meeting yeah it was
similar because you go through all the
etiquette and so by the time you
actually get in front of her ears
i think i scared her
which i'm sure he's a treasonable of
heaven here but she came up and said i'm
going to do the queen's accent so what
do you do
and i was so excited i'm a space
scientist
[Applause]
that you're a space scientist right i
mean that's but i think it did give you
a bit of a frightening yeah yeah
thank you so much for being here we're
going to have another guest tom
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe